[Music]  and a dream it was like I was being  called as a gold calling go I am flesh  and I am Bo's eighty-eight ting ting  lost my house I lost everything and my  soul rise up to most people have been  there but I mean do you want the ballet  of King had a dream oh my god do you  walk in the shadow of men who sold their  lives to a dream we got a gold mine we  gotta go by we believe you're [ __ ]  on the largest gold find of the decade  we're talking over thirty billion  dollars how does it feel to be a rock  star there's no way I could possibly  describe the feeling but it's amazing a  little gold can just change everything  some seems too good to be true it  usually is for better or worse the ride  had begun and what a goddamn ride  and I said he's gained I will marry you  with his hands what happened at the  meeting you want to talk about the truth  17 billion dollars disappeared overnight  in this money not our money oh mama I'm  in fear for my life on the long baby